qu'est ce qui rompt caramélisées à
l'extérieur est typiquement bordelais
c'est le cannelé un petit gâteau remise
en vogue il ya bientôt un an mais qui en
réalité est né il ya deux siècles
souhaité effet la première fois par les
soeurs de la miséricorde oui la série 4
l on fait ça pour se faire un petit peu
d'argent qu'on me demande de ces pour
pouvoir vivre et vous avez retrouvé dans
les archives la façon dont il peut être
pas totalement
il a fallu chercher un moment quand même
pour arriver à une recette qui soit
commerciale est quand même assez facile
à faire
hong kong perde pas trop dessus ne
manquent pas et puis que ce soit
réellement bon reparti à la conquête des
gourmands le 24 mars dernier avec la
naissance d'une confrérie le cannet fait
une belle offensive plus aucune
réception sans lui on le retrouve même
sur certaines tables parisienne et
londonienne et les pâtissiers ont
l'ambition d'en produire 1000 par jour
quant à la recette elle est simple mais
reste le tour de minces c'est ce qui
fait la différence
au fait vous y avez ensuite d'un sur un
papier ou mettez la composition farine
sucre
bien mélanger le film un rapide main
versez cette composition dans une
terrine vous mettez vos chambres dans le
milieu et à ce mois lorsque le lait bout
il y aurait mis du beurre dans le lait
et à ce moment là vous pouvez faire le
mélange rapidement et vivement
sans oublier évidemment en dernier le
parfum vanille rond
c'est le reproche qu'on lui fait un
petit cadeau les gens qui connaissent
pas n'ont pas très envie d'en goûter sa
fé noir
et oui ça choque un peu au départ mais
c'est ce noir qui fait la qualité du
cannabis puis cela parce que il est noir
à l'extérieur et à l'intérieur c'est
tout à fait moi le c'est tout à fait bon
à manger c'est le contraste du de
croustillant et moelleux à l'intérieur
mais pourquoi vous voulez et quand vous
voulez mais vous les migrants pollender
chose voir comment ils sont conciliants
à un moment où sommes nous